if 2016's doom was a modern 101 course
in ripping and tearing doom eternal is
your master class in the art of demon
dismemberment its software channels all
the aggression and speed of its
contemporary take on demon blasting into
a brainy or more cerebral dance of death
it challenges you not only to be light
on your feet and quick with your aim but
to be constantly aware of your
environment your adversaries your
capabilities and your limitations
there's a lot to keep track of which can
lead you to struggle getting through the
game's learning curve but during its
strongest moments of which there are
many doom eternal makes you feel like a
monster shredding badass not just
because you're the strongest doom Slayer
but because you're also the smartest the
fundamental changes of doom eternal
compared to doom 2016 are an how you get
the things you need to stay alive back
our dooms glory kilts where you stagger
an enemy to initiate a brutal takedown
which usually includes ripping off a
part of their body and forcibly
integrating it into another part in doom
2016 glory kills turn enemies into
pinatas of health armor and ammo but
eternal changes that equation glory
kills now only give you health while
killing enemies you set on fire with a
new flamethrower gives you armor and
chainsawing enemies gives you ammo you
have to balance all three kill types to
keep yourself going the overall effect
is that you can't just run around
blasting madly you have to run around
blasting rationally every fight in Doom
eternal requires constant calculus do
you have enough bullets in the right gun
to take down this enemy can you damage
someone enough for a quick health boost
while you're on the run should you put
your effort into knocking out the big
guy who's chasing you or take a second
to snipe off the weapons of a distant
monster by making use of doom eternals
new enemy weak points
most fights take place in big elaborate
multi-level arenas adorned with jump
pads and monkey bars that help you get
around quickly
you're also equipped with a double jump
and a quick horizontal dash that lets
you avoid attacks and cross distances
like everything else positioning has to
be on your mind constantly in doom
eternal if you aren't moving you're
dying
if that sounds overwhelming you're right
it definitely can be watching your ammo
counters or your health counters
assessing threats on the battlefield
picking your paths as you move around
arenas knowing when to fire grenades or
to freeze enemies finding guys to set on
fire and hack up with your chainsaw it's
all a lot to keep track of it's easy to
get thrown out of the joy at battle at
points when you're continually calling
up your weapon wheel to see what you've
still got bullets in or trying to swap
to the correct weapon mod to deal with
the monster currently ripping your face
off there are a lot of things you have
to manage in doom eternal and getting
into the rhythm of that management can
take a while
an eternal can definitely be frustrating
especially in summer eanes where it's
easy to accidentally get stuck in a
corner or back straight over a cliff
eternal isn't a mindless shooter where
you can get into a flow and let your
muscle-memory and reflexes do the work
it's a mind full shooter where every
second requires you to be plotting your
next move especially as you're getting
used to it constantly switching between
attacks and chasing enemies for pickups
can feel antithetical to the fast and
explosive approach players expect from
doom but while it all can be a bit much
eternal is brimming with moments when
all the pieces come together especially
after a few hours of getting the hang of
them it's like the twitch shooter
equivalent of a really great puzzle game
where your success comes from a full
understanding of every single systems
intricacies and your mind and body unify
to execute some ridiculous gory mayhem
doom eternals greatly increased mobility
and creative level design or where the
game really kicks into a metal guitar
solo and start shredding
especially in its best designed arenas
you're always repositioning taking
opportunities to fill your Larter's with
health and ammo and prioritizing threats
to tune the fight to your liking once
you get the rhythm of eternal it becomes
a brilliant extension of what made doom
2016 so cool and eternal is great at
providing heart-pounding moments when
you barely manage to slice off an
opponent's head just in time to shower
yourself with health and cheap death
then spin around and blast a big foe
with a rocket suddenly tipping the odds
in your favor just about every fight
feels like a speeding train seconds from
going off the rails with disaster only
averted because you're so damn good at
killing stuff there are a ton of fights
in Doom eternal and nearly every one of
them is a heart-pounding
white-knuckle struggle for survival well
the intricacies of combat are the big
focus in doom eternal there's a lot of
other stuff going on too there's an even
bigger focus on platforming and puzzling
out how to traverse levels and find the
myriad secrets and upgrades scattered
within them isn't welcome breather
between fights the platforming is still
a bit iffy at times especially when you
need to make a long jump to grab monkey
bars or sticky walls but falls into the
abyss no longer kill you
making these portions of the game pretty
forgiving there's also a fairly involved
story stretch through doom eternal
although good luck following it if you
don't take the time to read the many
collectible or drops scattered around a
turtle's approach to its storytelling
feels like a fundamental shift from the
satirical jokey approach in 2016 s doom
that game was about an energy company
that got rich off devil worship and a
protagonist who would literally punched
the radio's trying to give him context
for his constant mutilations eternal is
entirely more self-serious about Hell
invading earth filled with unexplained
proper nouns events and characters it
acts like you should be intimately
familiar with
and now you see to defy the call maker
herself and as your people's time now to
give penance just as it was mine knowing
what's going on isn't a necessary
component to enjoying the game which is
good because the story is completely
confusing doom eternal also features
master levels which are remixed story
missions meant to offer new and greater
challenges and a multiplayer mode but
neither were available ahead of launch I
will be sinking some time and to doom
eternals additional offerings after
launch and will provide a full review
and a final score after I've had a
chance to test them out with its
intricate combat in level designs doom
eternal manages to elevate all the
things that may do 2016 work so well its
combat is quick and chaotic but it
requires you to constantly analyze
everything that's happening in order to
come out victorious eternal takes some
time to get used to but find its rhythm
and it will reward you with a stream of
ridiculous intense moments that will
scratch your demon slaying itch all
while making you feel like a combat
survive
[Applause]